thanks to all the independent developers
set to launch their products on Steam
the PC will get hundreds of platform
exclusives this year rounding them up
would prove unwieldly so we've narrowed
the field down to this list of some of
the most high-profile games be sure to
subscribe and we'll keep you up to date
on everything coming to PC fimble we'd
part is the latest point-and-click
adventure game by veteran game
developers ron gilbert and gary Winnick
who are primarily known for their work
on LucasArts adventure games like maniac
mansion and The Secret of Monkey Island
Warhammer 40k space wolf is a turn-based
tactical card game that follows the
exploits the space mole faction of the
space marines divinity original sin 2
expands upon its critically acclaimed
predecessor by introducing new elemental
interactions the ability to play with up
to three other players
greater freedom to explore the world and
more routine is a first-person survival
horror game set on an abandoned Space
Station that evokes the atmospheric
qualities of late 70s sci-fi films the
Bard's Tale 4 is the latest entry in the
iconic dungeon crawler series you play
as a bard on a quest to save the land
from dark forces over land is a squad
based survival strategy game with
procedurally generated levels set in the
dangerous frontier of post-apocalyptic
North America a hat in time is a
colorful 3d platformer inspired by
classic games in the genre such as banjo
kazooie in super mario 64
escape from tarkov is an MMO that
combines first-person shooter action
with RPG and survival elements Frozen
Synapse
2 is a turn-based tactical game where
you command squads through covert
missions in an open procedurally
generated city hello neighbor is a
stealth horror game where you sneak into
your neighbor's house and try to uncover
the dark secrets inside Warhammer 40k
Dawn of War 3 is the latest entry in the
realtime strategy series based on the
universe and characters with a popular
tabletop game Warhammer 40k Zeno knots 2
is a strategy game where you command a
multinational organization defending
cold war-era earth from an alien
invasion agony is a first-person horror
game that forces you to survive the
depths of
hell aqua knocks deep descent is a
first-person shooter where you control a
submarine two undersea caverns in the
dystopian world of aqua lone echo is a
sci-fi action VR game where you explore
an advanced mining facility within the
rings of Saturn as sinister mystery
begins to emerge it also has a
multiplayer sports mode called Echo
Arena where you and up to four other
players attempt to throw rings in the
opposing team's goal Robo recall is a
first-person VR shooter launching
exclusively for oculus touch it puts you
in control of an agent working for an
organization tasked with eliminating
rogue robots
Arctica 0.1 is a first-person VR shooter
designed by 4a games the studio behind
the well-received Metro 2033 and Metro
last light and that's all the major PC
exclusives confirmed for 2017 but
there's still time for more to be
confirmed this year so let us know in
the comments below what other games you
think will come out for more on PC and
all your tech needs keep it locked onto
GameSpot
[Music]